[Musik]
fake news das sind falsche nachrichten
die den fakten widersprechen papst
franziskus unterstützt trump oder bill
gates möchte mit hilfe von impfungen die
weltbevölkerung reduzieren diese meldung
sind frei erfunden
trotzdem wurden sie millionenfach
geklickt hinter fake news stehen in
aller regel zwei motive erstens die
einflussnahme auf politische debatten
und zweitens das verdienen von geld
durch werbeeinnahmen
grundsätzlich gilt beim medienkonsum
skeptisch bleiben sind die headlines
besonders reißerisch formuliert werden
vor allem ängste und emotionen
angesprochen dass werden typische
verdachtspunkte dass es sich um fake
news handeln könnte ein erster schritt
um diesen verdacht nachzugehen ist das
überprüfen der quelle ist die verlinkte
webseite bekannt und gilt sie als
vertrauenswürdig falls nein sind die
wichtigsten informationen des verlinkten
artikels auch in anderen seriösen medien
aufgegriffen worden
zweiter schritt sind experten die in den
fragwürdigen artikeln auftauchen
wirklich unabhängig und glaubwürdig auch
hier kann eine suchanfrage helfen
schritt nummer drei wenn sich der
fragwürdige beitrag vor allem um ein
foto dreht kann eine bilder
rückwärtssuche klarheit schaffen
oft sind die bilder in einem völlig
anderen kontext entstanden als es die
fake news suggerieren eine weitere
anlaufstelle sind plattformen die
sogenannte faktenchecks machen die meist
geteilten feld - wurden dort auf bereits
geprüft und enttarnt habt ihr auch schon
einmal fake news in euren sozialen
netzwerken erkannt schreibt uns gerne in
die kommentare